Soon the world will split and
black chaos will emerge from the cracks
Borderless is the establishment of a stage to protect humankind Against the new age of
terrorism A completely new
organization,
the human race A single spear that pierces through the evils of this world You are
far from an ideal  You lose all your ability to be popular
[Music] I
know you, I know you
[Music] A transcendental
person who has surpassed even psychics The
strongest man in the detective agency See with your own eyes
Think with your own soul Defeat him  There is no choice but to open the case of Bako
[music]
Did the prophecy that should not come true come true